la enfermedad diverticular es una
afección que ocurre cuando se forman
bolsas hacia el final del intestino
grueso
el intestino grueso también conocido
como colon incluye el ciego
el colon ascendente el colon transverso
el colon descendente el colon sigmoide o
el recto y el canal anal
la pared del colon tiene cuatro capas
principales la mucosa
la submucosa
una capa muscular
y la aceros a exterior
los vasos sanguíneos llamados masa recta
suministran sangre al colon
aunque la causa se desconoce la
diverticulosis está asociada a una dieta
baja en fibra
al estreñimiento y a una atención
frecuente al hacer las deposiciones
el estreñimiento provoca aumento de la
presión dentro del colon
el aumento de la presión puede hacer que
la mucosa y la submucosa se hernia en
una zona debilitada de la pared del
colon y que se forme un divertículo
la diverticulosis ocurre cuando existen
estos divertículos pero a menudo no
presenta otros síntomas
por el contrario la diverticulitis
ocurre cuando los divertículos se
inflaman
[Música]
los síntomas habituales de la
diverticulitis son dolor abdominal en la
parte inferior izquierda fiebre
estreñimiento o diarrea y disminución
del apetito
la diverticulitis puede provocar una
acumulación de pus denominada absceso
la hinchazón excesiva y la acumulación
de pus pueden conducir a la formación de
una perforación a través de la cual el
pus y otro material se filtrarán hacia
el abdomen esta es una condición muy
grave y requiere atención médica
inmediata
si usted presenta un caso grave de
diverticulitis es posible que deba
someterse a un procedimiento para drenar
un acceso
si el problema persiste es posible que
necesita una cirugía para extirpar la
parte afectada del colon durante el
procedimiento el cirujano pasará el
extremo que queda del colon a través de
la pared abdominal creando una abertura
llamada estoma después de que el colon
haya cicatrizado podrá ser unido
nuevamente al recto
el tratamiento principal para la
diverticulosis es el aumento del consumo
de alimentos ricos en fibra para
suavizar y dar volumen a las heces lo
cual ayuda a estimular el colon para que
se contraiga y las elimine
y otros tratamientos para la
diverticulitis constan de una dieta de
líquidos claros y antibióticos orales